[Applaudissements]
c'est en 1995 après plusieurs siècles de
sommeil que la colline Souffrière est
revenue à la vie évacué à plusieurs
reprises la population restait confiante
mais en 1997 une nuit ardente du 19
personnes et ravages 60% du territoire
Lille est alors segmentée en zone nommée
en fonction de leur dangerosité
quand on parle de nous les gens disent
qu'on est résilient et c'est un peu vrai
mais je crois que face au désastre et ce
n'est pas propre à mon serra on est tous
résilient
bien que le volcan soit calme les
vulcanologues chaque semaine dans un
bulletin nous disent que ça peut
recommencer à n'importe quel moment
alors on ne peut pas complètement se
détendre en se disant que tout est fini
le volcan est potentiellement toujours
actif depuis 1997 des scientifiques
garde 24 heures sur 24 les yeux rivés
sur le volcan ils travaillent pour le
MVO
l'observatoire volcanologique de
Montserrat les gens de Montserrat ne
veulent pas vraiment entendre parler de
nos résultats scientifiques ils veulent
correspondre à cette question est-ce que
je suis en sécurité est-ce que ma maison
est en sécurité et c'est la réponse plus
difficile à leur apporter nous on a
trois principaux éléments qui nous
permettent de surveiller l'activité
volcanique le premier ce sont les
tremblements de terre des micros
secousses qui nous indiquent que le
magma bouge c'est signé au très
révélateur ou parviennent de nos
stations GPS ils sont envoyés sont nos
ordinateurs nous surveillons aussi la
déformation du sol quand la physionomie
de la montagne change le magma pousse et
bien c'est un impact sur le volcan en
lui-même il gonfle ou il se rétracte et
le troisième instrument de mesure c'est
le volume de gaz qui s'échappe
en combinant toutes ces mesures ça vous
dit si l'éruption est terminée ou si
elle est à venir
la dernière éruption du volcan date de
2008 et les instruments du mv-o avaient
détecté quelques jours avant l'explosion
une activité souterraine anormale d'un
perceptible tremblement de terre
enregistré par le sismographe
regardez on avait détecté jour après
jour de plus en plus ces micro
tremblements de terre et ça indiquait
que quelque chose était en train de se
passer le lendemain là il y avait
tellement de mines secousses qu'on y
arrivait plus à les compter ça tremblait
continuellement
et c'est ce qu'on appelle les
oscillations et ça indique que le magma
est en mouvement
et le jour suivant
on a ce signal fort ça correspond à
l'explosion à la surface
les premiers jours de ces micro
tremblements de terre on le voit rien à
la surface et ce jour-là on a eu
l'explosion
en ce moment le volcan semble calme on
n'a pas eu d'activité sismique de
surface depuis 7 ans
mais le volume de gaz qui s'échappe est
beaucoup trop élevé et la déformation du
sol est beaucoup trop importante pour un
volcan en sommeil il y a bien quelque
chose là-dedans qui ne demande qu'à
sortir
[Musique]